[Music]
hello YouTube chest lowers my friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 36th episode of dirty
chest tricks in this video I'm going to
continue the second part of my tricky
line against names of Larsen attack
which arises after the following water
b3 ePHI Bishop to b2 Knight to c6 III
defy Bishop to b5 so what is threatening
the move Bishop captures ePHI so black
plays Bishop to d6
and white continue with his attacking
style a4 pressurizing more on e5 and
accordingly black continue with AB 6 now
in the last episode I have covered the
move f captures Aoife and the move
Knight to f3 and we conclude that in
most of the case not only black get the
advantageous position but White has to
be very careful to avoid lots of tricks
and traps in this episode we are going
to see what happens if I choose the
second most popular choice Queen to h5
check well black responses force black
has to play g6 and now white idea is to
play Queen to h4 and thus he can argue
that he has weakened this even to etch a
diagonal which later on creates some
problems in the black camp well yes
indeed to some extent it's true but I
think after black's next reply that is e
captures f4 it is now wide who needs to
know lot of stuff to fight for the
equalizer now as per the theory there
are two main moves in this position and
let's look each by tone the first move I
want to consider is he captures f4 which
looks more natural in this position but
after Bishop to d7 not only black get an
advantageous position but why needs to
continue with accurate moves
to avoid some nasty pitfalls the good
point
I like about this position is it doesn't
matter whether white continue its any
moves black planning of campaign is very
easy he wants to play Knight to be four
pressurizing the C 2 square and also
exchanging the light square bishop which
speed up his development
now to understand whatever I have said
let's consider the most popular choice
by white that is Knight to e2 all other
replies has been covered in detail which
are available in the pigeon so kindly
check it out ok Knight to be for
pressurizing the c2 as well as promoting
the exchange
now instead of night 2 before there is
one important point I like to mention
here that night to b4 is a very
technical line so if you don't like that
line then the second alternative here is
Queen to e7 and a simple line can draw
like this castle on the kingside castle
on the Queen side rook to e1 and now
simple quint web 7 so this is a more
strategic setup by black where you can
see I have highlighted by the arrows
very effective plan by the black and
because white knight sitting on b1 white
attack on black king is very slow I have
attached a model game in the PGN where a
2500 plus GM easily able to crush a
2,200 rated opponent and that game gives
you a great idea how to handle such
positions personally I like Knight to be
full because it's very direct white
responses force white has to first
capture this bishop and after Queen
captures d7 as Black is threatening to
capture on c2 White has to play Knight
to a3 now instead of night to a
three-in-one blitz game my opponent try
the move Knight to d4 which doesn't turn
out well because after the move Bishop
to c5 he thought that he can easily
escape from this
with the mu III but what he overlooked
is after Bishop captures d4 by force
white is losing a piece and in fact the
game so that's why here
Knight to a3 is a force reply well after
that black is going to continue with
castle on the Queen side and blacks
overall aim in this position is to
target this lose night on the a3 square
here white can decide whether to castle
or capture on f6 capturing on f6 at this
point is not a good choice the simple
reason is after Knight captures up six
Queen capture sep 6 and the move rook to
e8 in the long run what is not able to
castle and to show you how poisonous
this position is for white in the
database one game continue from here
King to have fun black played Queen to
g4 pressurizing the e2 night if rope to
even then rook to f8 is a very strong
reply so in the game white played the
Moon Knight to d4 which turns out as a
big time disaster black plays rook to e4
more pressure on f4 so I naturally
defend it with the move g3 but after
rook to f8 white is completely busted
the game finished very quickly Quinn to
g7 and now the obvious dazzling
sacrifice boom hahaha
why took it but after Queen check King
to even Queen check Knight to e2 Queen
check nitrogen
Queen check King to e2 and after having
so many pieces in the launch black
delivered this wonderful checkmate
so here it is very clear that white
cannot even touch that pond the more
stable choice over here is to castle
first and then looking to capture on f6
and surprisingly enough black is going
to allow this with the mu H file what
black is arguing is okay you can take on
f6 but my attack is rolling down on your
King site if I'd continued with smooth
such as rook a to even then King 2b it
is a very strong reply and I have
attached a sample line in the PG n so
the obvious question need to be arise
what happens if white try to recapture
his pawn with Bishop captures f6
well here it turns out that it is more
dangerous than last line because after
Knight captures up six Queen captures f6
and rook s to e 8 just within 14 moves
black obtained a decisive advantage
there are three choices for the white in
this position
neither of them solve any problems in
the white camp the first more I want to
consider is rook to f2 which can easily
dealt with the move d4 if I take this d4
pawn then there comes Knight to d5 and
white is going to lose a piece so that's
not a good idea what happens if your
opponent goes night to d4 well we can
continue with the move Knight to c6
attacking on a3
and it doesn't matter where ever this
night goes black obtained of Vinh engage
if Knight to be fire then after Bishop
to c5 King to h1 and rook to f8 white
loses a piece and instead of night to be
fire if your plan plays Knight to beavin
then the easiest is you continue with
Bishop to c5 and after the force replies
c3 the same tactics rook to e6 Queen to
G Phi and Knight takes d4 white cannot
capture that piece
finally what happens if you open and
continue with the Moon Knight to c3
which has been played in two games but
I'm afraid this is even worst because
after the move rook to e6 attacking the
Queen Queen to h4 and Knight to c6
creates the same problem in the white
camp he cannot go night to be fire the
simple reason is after Bishop check King
to h1 and the MU a6 white lost piece and
instead of night to be fire the
interesting part is if he goes to the b1
square then white has another problem
namely the C to pawn and black can
exploit this immediately with Knight to
deform I have one a very quick game in
this line where my 2188 opponent
continued with the move rook to c1
defending the c2 I continue with Bishop
to c5 so there's a discover attack on
King so my opponent continued with King
to h1 but after rook to e8 you can
already see pitiable position of the
white camper there's a threat of either
night to c2 or Knight to f5 which white
cannot peri and in the game I decided to
clear his back rank with s3 but this is
not sufficient as after Knight to f5
this Queen has to by force lose the
control of the even square he played
Queen to g5 but after rook check rook
captures rook captures King to s2 Bishop
to Jeevan check King to h1 and now the
nice deflecting move Queen to e7 and it
turned out that it doesn't matter
whatever white plays his King is not
going to survive longer in the game due
to the time trouble
my opponent take this Queen but then
after one move Knight to g3 create a
devastating checkmate
so by this analysis it is very obvious
that if I'd continued with the move II
kept a cell phone then the resulting
position is quite superior photo black
now before making this line I have gone
through various books and videos of GM's
and many of them have recommended the
move Knight to f3 at this position
completely committing upon what they are
claiming is after F captures III and the
MU Castle white gasps tremendous
activity on the black King well I'm
afraid it's not that true and in their
analysis they have mainly considered
moves such as King to f7 King to f8 or
even pawn captures d2 but they have all
missed this critical move Bishop to d7
and I think after this move there is
hardly any compensation for the extra
pawn in the database eighty percent of
the game continued with the move Bishop
to d3 and in fact that is the main line
but anyways if your opponent plays other
moves such as Knight to c3 or rook -
even then I have covered those line in
detail which are available in the BGN to
give you a brief idea how good those
lines are for black if you opera and
continue with Knight to c3 attacking on
d5 then black and simply played in
Knight to e7 why doesn't have time to go
back because then the second pawn hangs
so by force white has to capture this
Bishop and after Queen takes he has to
regain on e3 but then comes Bishop to c5
and then you can see by the arrows the
simple but very effective plan of
campaign by black and in all these
visions
do not forget black is a clear pawn
so that means white has to play
energetically to compensate for his
extra pawn and accordingly Bishop to d3
is a mainline because here what is
threatening the move Bishop captures g3
and black needs to know what he is going
to do about it well after a lot of
research I come to conclusion that after
the MU e - in almost all the variation
black obtained a slight advantage and in
fact over the board it's not easy to
play as a white there are mainly four
options available for the white and
let's look at each by town the first
obviously we need to know if Bishop
captures e6 is walking in this position
and the answer is not because after pawn
captures g6 Queen captures h8 Black has
this move pawn captures rook with a
queen and after Queen takes and the move
Bishop to e6 after the all complications
black emerged with an extra piece the
second move rook to f2 we can straight
away dismiss because after the move
Bishop to c5 White has a huge problem
and even in this case Bishop captures g6
doesn't work well for the white the
third mu I want to consider is Bishop
captures e - but if that bishop has to
go back then doesn't black position get
better
well answer is yes of course a simple
line which gives black comfortable
advantage goes like this Queen to e7
White has tried two options but neither
of them walking very good if Knight to
c3 then the simplest is you castle on
the Queen side which at first sight
looked very strange because white can
capture on defy attacking to spot but
technically this is working for black as
after Queen captures a two
Knight captures f6 so there's a discover
x-ray going on on the etch it rook but
once again after Knight captures f6
Bishop captures f6 and the wonderful
saving resource Bishop to e7 everything
is in control for the black the most
critical response here is Luke a to even
but after Bishop captures up six Queen
captures AB six and the move Queen to be
five black emerge with an extra piece
the second move rook to even looks more
threatening but once again after Castle
why doesn't have a single threat in this
position one of my game against the
national master continue from here
Bishop to c4 so my opponent attacking on
D file I simply play Queen to f7
defending all the thread so my opponent
forcefully moved the bishop once again
with Bishop to b5 okay Bishop to c5
check if he played e4 then after Bishop
to d6 black clearly merged with an extra
pawn and the pressure of the long
diagonal has completely gone so
accordingly
my opponent plays King to h1 but that
comes chief i hitting the Queen Queen to
g3
and now Knight G to e7 so black has a
simple threat of night to fi my opponent
played Bishop to d3 but you can easily
see that after the move H Phi whose
position is better and in fact black has
an extra pawn considering all the
options so far I think rook to e1 is a
most accurate choice by the white and
against this you have two good choices
Knight to e5 gives a very solid and
equal position and if you are playing
against a hiring opponent you should
certainly consider this option but more
dynamic is king to f7 and after this
once again black has a very clear-cut
blonde in the position it doesn't matter
whether you're upon place any
highlighted moves night before is the
next obvious choice by the black here
the route kept us e to is a most popular
choice however if you open in place
let's say Knight to c3 then after Knight
to be for attacking the bishop and
Bishop cannot move anywhere as the c2
point drops so the force replies rook
captures e to and after that Knight
captures Bishop pawn captures and the
move c6 not only black has a solid
position with extra pawn advantage but
white has some shattered pawn on the
center and this position is quite good
for the black so let's check out what
happens if you open place route captures
e to our plan doesn't change we are
going to continue with Knight to be for
attacking the bishop and this is what I
like about this move this Bishop doesn't
have any good Square and once you take
this Bishop all the pressure of the
white is completely diffuse now to
understand the future plans and ideas I
like to show you a game between two GM
wear white continue with the move Knight
to e3 black continue with the obvious
move Knight captures d3 pawn captures d3
and now King to g7 so you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows a very simple
plan by black that is he wants to play
c6 consolidate his extra pawn and then
he wants to play Knight to at 6 Knight
to f5 hitting the Queen and asking white
where does your compensation lies don't
forget what has this horrible double
pawn which is always a headache in the
endgame let's see this plan live in
action
rook a to even happens Knight to f6
Knight to d4 white is coming on e6 but
black doesn't bother about it he
continued with the move rook to f8
Knight to e6 check happen black
responses force Bishop takes rook takes
and at first sight it looks like white
has created some pressure on f6 but it
is just an illusion as after Bishop
check King to h1 and the Moon Knight to
f5 by force white has to move the Queen
Queen to f4 happens and now the obvious
move h-file
stopping any g4 idea by white white
continue with the move Knight to B Phi
so eyeing at the d4 square and black
consolidate his position with the MU c6
Knight to d4 happen and we have the few
exchanges that is Bishop captures d4
Bishop captures d4 Knight captures D fo
Queen captures default and now rook to
f7 and I think we should stop over here
you can check out rest of the game in
the PG in but one can easily see that
for a sec rifice pawn white never get an
attack and in the resulting position not
only black emerge with an extra pawn but
White has some horrible pawns on the
center of the board and this major piece
endgame if anybody is playing for the
win it is only black well I hope with
this brief analysis now you literally
pray that you open and place the names
Larson attack so you can throw this
surprising weapon and get the full point
due to the time constraint I cannot able
to show every single line in this video
so kindly check out the PGN where I have
covered most of the line in the detail
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care